an extraordinary event here this morning
Joe Biden visiting Kiev amid
extraordinary security I have to say
extraordinary secrecy as well on the
Americans part on the ukrainians part we
knew something was up when internet went
down we were told that we had to stay in
the hotel we weren't allowed to film I
did manage to see I have to say from our
Vantage Point here Joe Biden turning up
at a memorial wall here in Kiev with a
wreath he oversaw the laying of the reef
at that memorial wall a wall that
commemorates the fallen in this war and
Joe Biden did that he then got in his
car and made his way away we presume
that he's seen president zelenski no
official detail at the moment other than
the fact that we have seen Joe Biden in
Kiev this morning it's his first visit
to the wartime Capital as I say he laid
that reef and what made it so
extraordinary was that the air raid
sirens were sounding in this capital
city as he was doing that and it just
went on normally uh the the event took
place but these Air Raid Sirens uh were
going now there have been several
suggestions that
Joe Biden would come to Kiev at some
stage plans were made in the past in
previous months but it was always
considered
well too risky and those uh plans were
aborted he clearly thinks so that this
is the moment Ian for him to come he is
due in Poland uh in the next 24 48 hours
to meet the Polish president uh Duda
he's going to speak to what are called
the NATO Eastern flank Nations and he
will be you know
reinforcing American Support
for the ukrainians and what better way
to do that than to come to this capital
city
the Americans are the biggest supporters
in terms of military aid for Ukraine and
this will be a very big historic
political moment for Joe Biden and for
the ukrainians